-Salut Romain! Y'a encore une manif?
-Et oui...
-Et pourquoi?
-T'avais promis une vidéo, et tu l'as pas faite...
Ok, c'est bon.
Dans ma vidéo sur les règles j'avais fait un petit "disclaimer" qui n'est pas passé inaperçu
(Rembobinage)
Toutes les femmes n'ont pas leurs règles et toutes les personnes qui ont leurs règles ne sont pas des femmes
alors pour plein de raisons et notamment dans le cas des personnes transgenres qui méritent évidemment
une vidéo dédiée. Voilà le moment d'en reparler est venu c'est aujourd'hui. Alors déjà avant de commencer on va se mettre d'accord
l'expression "changer de sexe" ça reflète pas la réalité. Du coup vous allez me dire:
"Bah pourquoi t'appelles ta vidéo comme ça alors?" Ah bah, c'est parce que c'est l'expression la plus employée
notamment par les gens qui savent pas précisément de quoi il s'agit. Et que le but de DTC c'est justement de donner des infos au plus
grand nombre donc on va commencer tout de suite on va parler de transidentité
parce qu'en vrai c'est pas changer de sexe c'est beaucoup plus complexe
et l'idée c'est d'expliquer ça juste avant de comprendre comment ça se passe en pratique
c'est pas mal de comprendre
de quoi on parle. Parce qu'il y'a plein de mots et plein d'expressions pas forcément claires et même pas forcément exactes qui sont utilisés sur
le sujet
Alors, je vais pas vous faire une explication de texte mais je vous mets un lien vers un lexique dans la description de la vidéo.
juste pour comprendre: on naît tous avec un sexe biologique, nos organes génitaux externes et internes
Pour résumer: pénis, testicules, prostate
vulve, vagin, clitoris, utérus, etc.
On va pas en parler aujourd'hui mais sachez qu'on peut
aussi avoir des caractéristiques biologiques
des deux sexes. Et donc à la naissance,
vous savez comment ça se passe, une vulve (hop!) c'est une fille; un pénis (hop!) c'est un garçon.
Ça c'est: le sexe
et le genre c'est tout ce qu'on accroche dessus.
Au sens figuré, hein? Je parle de codes sociaux pas de piercings
Le genre c'est ce qui définit ce qui est féminin et ce qui est masculin
et tout ce qui va avec. Toutes les conventions sociales qui y sont liés: les traits de caractère, les goûts, etc.
En grandissant, il arrive qu'on se rende compte que notre sexe et notre genre
bah ça colle pas... Je parle de personnes qui se sentent qui se vivent comme appartenant à un genre
qui correspond pas au sexe biologique qui leur a été attribué
et pour ces personnes on peut se poser à un moment de leur vie la question
de faire coïncider les deux et donc de faire une
transition. C'est à dire de vivre et d'être au regard de la société
selon leur propre genre et pas celui défini par leur sexe. La transition ça peut aussi concerner des personnes qui ne se sentent pas appartenir
exclusivement à l'un de ses deux genres
Mais bon, concrètement, comment on fait?
C'est pas juste une opération chirurgicale c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça.
Une transition même si la loi permet de la faire et qu'elle a évoluée encore aujourd'hui ça reste un parcours du combattant
notamment parce que le genre ça se retrouve dans plein d'aspects de la vie:
l'aspect physique, c'est vrai, mais aussi l'aspect psychologique,
social et l'état civil par exemple. D'ailleurs pour une transition tout le monde n'a pas forcément le même parcours, tout le monde ne choisit pas forcément
d'intervenir sur tous ces aspects
évidemment ce qui complique les choses c'est qu'il ya toujours des gens qui viennent coller leur nez dans les affaires des autres
et donner leur avis voir leur jugement mais bon on va s'intéresser au concret et à la façon dont ça se passe en France.
On va commencer par l'aspect physique:
bon alors déjà, à ce stade, tout le monde ne choisit pas la même voie. On n'est pas obligé de passer par un parcours médical
pour certains, et suivant les cas, ça passe par de la muscu, des vêtements compressifs pour masquer les formes, ou des séances d'épilation,
des greffes de cheveux, etc. On peut aussi apprendre à modifier sa voix chez un orthophoniste
voir faire un peu de chirurgie esthétique au niveau du visage.
Chacun fait en fonction de son apparence de départ et de ses envies ou de ses besoins.
Pour celles et ceux qui choisissent la voie médicale
ça commence chez le psychiatre. La loi ne l'exige pas mais il se trouve qu'une majorité des médecins et des chirurgiens qui interviennent dans les transitions
réclament un certificat d'un psy: ce que dénoncent les associations
des personnes trans. Donc vous l'avez compris le psy c'est pas pour être accompagné dans son coming out
ou être soutenu dans son parcours du combattant, c'est juste une espèce de "feu vert" pour la suite.
Officiellement pour déceler s'il n'y a pas une pathologie psychiatrique qui altérerait le jugement
et officieusement pour se couvrir au cas où la personne changerait d'avis
après coup et décidait de faire un procès. Cette évaluation, elle peut être longue, voire
très longue. Une fois qu'on a le sésame en poche on peut théoriquement
choisir les médecins et les chirurgiens qu'on veut pour faire sa transition. Il ya les équipes hospitalières dites
"spécialisées" auxquelles certaines associations de personnes trans ont pas mal de choses à reprocher
mais il ya aussi des praticiens qui font ça dans le privé.
Vous vous en douter quand on entreprend une transition
les choses peuvent être compliquées à mettre en place
et du coup c'est toujours une bonne idée d'être accompagné et prendre les conseils d'une association.
Ensuite, là encore il n'y a pas de procédure standard, il y a un certain nombre de traitements possibles mais rien d'obligatoire.
La première possibilité c'est
l'hormonothérapie
c'est à dire prendre des hormones masculinisantes ou féminisantes selon le genre vers lequel on transitionne
ça permet de développer ce qu'on appelle: des caractères sexuels secondaires.
En gros la voix, les poils, l'aspect de la peau,
la distribution des graisses sur le corps, le développement de la poitrine, etc. Il y a plein de médicaments différents qui sont données en fonction
des antécédents de la personne et qui nécessite bien sûr un suivi médical. Pour ce qui concerne les opérations chirurgicales
là encore il ya beaucoup d'options c'est la personne qui choisit. Ça peut être une rhinoplastie:
se faire refaire le nez, ou d'autres interventions au niveau du visage ou de la pomme d'adam. Ça peut être au niveau de la poitrine:
une mammectomie, c'est-à-dire, retirer les seins et reconstruire un torse ou au contraire poser des prothèses mammaires.
Et puis il y a la réassignation sexuelle:
ce que les gens appellent souvent "changer de sexe" et qui concerne les organes génitaux.
Contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser, c'est loin d'être la majorité des cas mais oui évidemment ça existe pour ce qui concerne exclusivement
les organes génitaux une fois de plus chaque cas est particulier
chacune et chacun choisit
l'intervention ou les interventions qui lui correspondent. L'hystérectomie, par exemple, c'est-à-dire retirer l'utérus, les trompes et les ovaires
c'est possible mais ce n'est pas systématique
on peut aussi choisir de subir juste d'une orchidectomie, c'est-à-dire retirer les testicules. Cela permet, par exemple, de diminuer les traitements hormonaux.
Et certaines personnes choisi de subir l'aïdoïopoïèse complète, bon ça c'est le terme médical, on dit aussi souvent
vaginoplastie. C'est une intervention qui consiste à façonner un vagin mais aussi un clitoris des grandes et des petites lèvres de façon chirurgicale.
Les grands principes de cette opération c'est que le résultat ai une apparence le plus naturel possible mais aussi bien sûr qu'il soit fonctionnel
sur le plan urinaire et sur le plan sexuel.
Pour arriver à ce résultat et sans rentrer dans les détails, on conserve au
maximum la peau et les structures de la verge mais aussi les nerfs. Côté pénis il ya plusieurs possibilités
la phallopoïèse d'abord
poïèse = création
phallus = bah phallus
"créer un pénis" littéralement. Là encore l'idée c'est de se rapprocher le plus possible du modèle original
mais c'est un peu plus compliqué parce que dans le cas précédent on retire des trucs là il faut en rajouter
la technique la plus courante c'est prélever de la peau avec les vaisseaux et les nerfs
le plus souvent au niveau de l'avant-bras mais aussi d'une cuisse ou d'ailleurs ensuite on en fait un pénis on le greffe
et dans un deuxième temps si tout va bien on peut y mettre une prothèse qui permettra l'érection. C'est une intervention
délicate qui ne fonctionne pas parfaitement à tous les coups. Il y a une alternative à cette technique
c'est la métaïdïoplastie qu'on appelle
aussi la "méta". En fait quand on prend des hormones comme la testostérone
le clitoris grossit et étant donné que comme on l'a vu dans la vidéo sur le sujet ces structures sont très semblables à celles du pénis
sa forme comme une sorte de petit pénis. L'opération consiste à le dégager pour qu'il soit bien à l'extérieur
Cette technique a moins de complications que la phallopoïèse,
elle évite les cicatrices sur les avant-bras ou sur les cuisses mais le pénis est plus petit et il est parfois moins fonctionnel
Encore une fois gardez en tête que tout ça ça concerne pas tout le monde loin de là parce que de nombreuses personnes n'ont pas
recours à la chirurgie il ya une espèce de fascination
par rapport à ça du coup il ya une tendance à réduire les personnes trans à leur corps alors que c'est plus une affaire d'identité
et de rapports sociaux. En marge des traitements médicaux et chirurgicaux il ya aussi les démarches pour changer de genre au niveau de l'état civil
changer de prénom déjà ça se fait en mairie et le changement de la mention sexe sur les papiers
ça c'est un juge du tribunal de grande instance qui s'en occupe. Depuis 2016 la loi précise qu'il n'est plus nécessaire d'avoir suivi de traitement
médical ou chirurgical
pour changer de sexe au niveau administratif
Maintenant que vous avez compris et avant de se quitter
On va faire le point sur 4 trucs à ne pas dire à une personne trans:
"Mais ta... Enfin ton..."
On vous demande souvent de parler de votre pénis et de votre vagin comme ça vous? Non.
Bah pareil en fait. Même si vous avez très envie de savoir, bah ça me regarde pas.
"Mais, comment tu fais l'amour?"
Même réponse. Vraiment.
"Mais du coup c'est quoi ton orientation sexuelle?"
Ça rien avoir en fait, c'est pas lié.
Une personne trans elle peut être hétéro, homo, bi,  asexuelle, etc.
"On sait pas si on doit dire "il" ou "elle"..."
Alors, petite astuce écouter la façon dont la personne se présente
et si vous avez un doute à vous poser la question gentiment si vraiment vous avez peur d'être blessant
vous temporisez, vous utilisez des pronoms neutre et vous attendez d'être fixé.
Voilà vous en doutez il y a plein d'autres trucs à pas dire mais on va déjà partir sur ces quatre là
ça sera un bon début donc vous avez vu la transition c'est un long parcours
psychiatrique, médical, chirurgical, social, administratif et judiciaire.
C'est surtout un long parcours humainement parlant
se heurte souvent à
l'incompréhension au
jugement voire aux agressions c'est ce qui fait que le taux de suicide chez les personnes trans
il est beaucoup plus élevé que dans la population générale
savoir c'est comprendre et c'est déjà un premier pas et maintenant vous vous savez
Voilà, DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui je tiens à remercier
Liam et l'association outrans pour leur aide précieuse je vous mets les liens dans la description.
On se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos, en attendant prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien :)